but the last of us on a Friday well I
might get this up Saturday morning it's
a little late right now sorry about that
so it looks like the universe recognizes
something has to give and since it's
called Super Bowl Sunday not the last of
us Sunday the last of us gets bumped to
Friday so here we are also going to talk
about spoilers for episode 5 of the HBO
series The Last of Us not going to talk
about anything spoiler based in the game
going forward or looking forward if you
don't know the plot of the game you are
safe but if you haven't seen episode 5
of The Last of Us and you still watch
this video well you're kind of screwed I
know we're halfway through season one of
The Last of Us in this episode I gotta
say starting to see some cracks in the
armor still an enjoyable show but there
are things most anything that this
episode made up that wasn't a part of
the game just wasn't as good as the game
I don't mean in the capacity of it's not
exactly like the game Ergo it's not as
good as the game that's not necessarily
true I think in the case of the
live-action last of us though in this
episode in particular I feel like this
episode overcooked a couple things
whereas the game just kept it in the
pocket if not kept it simple it's the
last episode we left off were Henry and
Sam meet Joel and Ellie now Henry and
Sam are hanging out with Joel and Ellie
now in the show they made a change with
Sam Sam is deaf in the show the
characters hearing impaired the actress
hearing impaired that does present an
opportunity to show the dynamic between
these two brothers and how in the show
Sam relies on his brother Moore to
survive this world in an episode that
shows that Sam might step on glass and
make noise when he doesn't know that
he's stepping on glass or making noise
in a world where there are zombies and
monsters that hone in on you on the
basis that you're making noise however I
do feel this show dropped the ball in
showing that Henry would have to be more
hardcore would have to get his hands
dirtier and the name of protecting his
brother in the show Henry's like aiming
a gun at you is the closest I've ever
come to being mean or however he said it
the whole time I was just thinking how
the [__] are you still alive so it's
funny how change works you make a change
to one character and it's gonna Trickle
and you're gonna have to make a change
to another character because the
situation is different but they didn't
in fact back the change they made was
like no and uh Henry's nicer in the show
than he was in the game not that Henry
wasn't nice in the game I'm just saying
he's like I feel like Henry in the game
would kick Henry in the show's ass these
are just little thoughts I've had but
where I feel they really overcooked it
is the backstory of Sam and Henry in the
leukemia treatment and so because in the
game it's just like we were a part of a
group we tried to take supplies from
this other group we got caught they
killed the other ones and now we're just
trying to get out of Dodge very simple
because most beefs in the apocalypse
will come down to food and supplies this
show was like What if Sam had leukemia
and then Henry needed treatment for
Sam's leukemia and this group had it and
so Henry goes to the group and the
group's like hey we want you to sell out
this other guy and then we'll give you
the meds and then Henry does it and then
Karen
is her name Kathleen
come on we were all thinking Karen now
she hates Henry because that guy that
Henry sold out for the leukemia meds for
his brother was her brother and so now
she's right it's it's just a bit
overcooked in a world like our world
where civilization hasn't fallen yet
where elitists keep [__] for themselves
you know what those in power would do
with leukemia meds in the zombie
apocalypse were resources are scarce
leukemia meds most of all yeah they
would keep it for themselves now I have
no doubt a deal would go down with
someone who needed leukemia meds for his
brother in the name of yeah you sell out
that person bring them to us we'll kill
him and then we'll give you leukemia
meds the deal would happen and then once
they had the guy that wanted to kill
they would kill that guy and then kill
the people they made the deal with and
they would keep the leukemia meds for
themselves look I aim to survive the
zombie apocalypse folks and I want you
to as well so just know that that's what
would happen in that scenario So Not
only was the scenario unbelievable it
was overly convoluted to a degree it
didn't need to be also I didn't care
about that whole plot line Kathleen like
if Kathleen's character if she was like
Sam Gerard and she's chasing Joel Ellie
Henry and Sam through the entire Series
yeah I'd want to know a bit more about
it but they all die in this episode so I
didn't need the backstory Sam Henry Joel
and Ellie that's that's the episode
right there spend more time with them
also I didn't buy her as a zombie
apocalypse later stop you put that
keyboard down I'm not saying women
cannot be leaders in the zombie
apocalypse Marlene apocalypse leader
qualities for days the vibe is there let
me look at Justified that lady not the
apocalypse but still I feel like she
could be an apocalypse leader she has
that Vibe of you screw me over and I'm
gonna kill your entire family in front
of you kind of lady casting's important
I just didn't buy her as a leader in
this shitty Fallen World but we're told
that she is and we're you know like the
dude even says like you got us out of a
tough spot we're following you we're
here for you this is another classic
case of the characters are telling the
audience what they're supposed to see
without showing them essentially the
second half of the episode got really
exciting yeah that big bloater [__] you
saw in the trailer coming out of the
ground whole horde of zombies I guess
they're not technically zombies though
they're zombies clickers they're zombies
whatever a whole horde of them come out
of the ground it's just it's a firefight
it's not in a firefight it's just what
you call spray and pray you're just
hoping you make it through it I'm not
buying the fact that a clicker is a
little girl clicker Ellie's hiding in a
car and this little clicker crawls into
the car a clicker that just operates on
sound a lot of gunfire going on out
there and apparently this thing was like
I hear something obviously there's a
girl in a car breathing but I do gotta
look back and touch on episode three
episode three how it feeds into a
episode 5 or at least how it did for me
it was actually quite smart that they
did episode three the way they did
because episode three was this
optimistic twist optimistic
comparatively when dealing with fungus
horror and uh zombies you know what I
mean the characters got a nicer
resolution than they had to get in the
world of The Last of Us that is to say
nicer than the game so in episode 5
anytime it looked like Sam and Henry
they might stay with Joel and Ellie
maybe they're not gonna die I kept
thinking that I'm like they kind of did
that before though the characters in
episode three did die but they have gone
against the game in the name of having a
nicer outcome for the characters so
there were quite a few times in this
episode I was like are they gonna live
are Sam and Henry gonna dude is it the
optimism of us now turns out no they
died just as horribly in the show as
they did in the game but still I had
doubts gotta say I appreciate that even
though I've played the game I still
didn't know how this was gonna play out
that's because of episode three so
although by and large I didn't enjoyed
this episode by the end hopefully I've
Illustrated why I say most of the things
they made up in this episode that
weren't in the game were better in the
game than this episode I feel like this
episode would have been better would
have been more heartbreaking it was
already heartbreaking absolutely but it
would have been harder hitting if we
spent more time with Sam and Henry
rather than the militia who gives a [__]
group led by the leader we don't care
about hope I'm not seeing diminishing
returns for the last of us but there's
part of me that feels like maybe I am
though to be fair to the show the show
started out pretty strong so if you're a
nine where do you go from there right
you hoping for ten don't hope for ten it
doesn't happen alright so The Last of Us
episode five have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
one thing I can say for certain is Joel
keeping the sniper rival after he killed
the snipers the most video game based
thing I've ever seen in a live-action
adaptation